thank you for joining us America we're
so glad you're with us is the Dave
Ramsey show Jackies with us in Columbia
South Carolina
hi Jackie how are you I'm fine thank you
for taking my call
sure what's up I want to know if I
co-signed a loan for my son six years
ago he's no 28 loan yes you know should
I make that a part of my baby steps too
since he's he's he's not paying it like
you're supposed to well when you co-sign
a loan and they don't pay it you get to
pay it that's why they wanted a cosigner
yeah so how much do you owe on the
student room almost 20,000 hmm
what's your household income seventy
okay and what does your son make oh he
just got a job about twenty dollars per
hour for making about 20 to 25 hours per
week he's working 20 hours a week yeah
okay what's he doing with the rest of
his time well he he doesn't want to have
a job that will conflict with this job
because he's been trying to get into
this job forever it could well I would
at conflict with this job he's only
working in 20 hours a week right since
he's on call for this job 20 hours a
week or the whole week 20 hours per week
maybe 24 hours it's a radius is a TV
station and he she just um goes in when
they have a football game and does the
games the switchboard at the game now
why would you be on call for football
there's no emergency football you've
been trying to get into the TV station
for years I got that part what he's
working 20 hours a week and his mother's
calling me because he can't pay his
dadgum $20,000 bill I'd like for him to
work
the 40 hours a week on top of the 20
he's playing with football Sochi they
can pay his freaking bill so you're not
calling me how would that sound that
would sound awesome I try to tell him
that I just I'm just gonna come to
realization I just and I have to see it
myself because he pays the 30 days late
at least 30 days late everybody don't
work much yeah there's a great place to
go when you're broke to work so what I
would tell him to do is get into
Financial Peace University and get his
young budding gear and start paying the
oh I mean if I'm you I'm gonna be all up
on this kid because he's 28 years old
and he's a slacker and his momma is
calling me are you single yes his mom's
a single lady I hear when you're 50 150
years old and you're having to pay this
kid's bills yeah I'm mad at him right
now and I want you to be too in a good
loving mama kind of way I'm not trying
to disown him I just want to knock a nod
on his little head okay yeah and then
yeah you better plan on paying it if
that little knot doesn't get moving
okay that snowball and knock it out and
then you just chalk it up to that and
but dude I'm telling you we're gonna
have some discussions is he married he
lives with a girlfriend okay
I'll bet she works 40 hours yeah there
you go hey guys thanks for watching if
you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
you
[Applause]
[Music]